how do many kinds of cells arise from a
single cell during development single
cell sequencing technologies and new
computational tools are providing the
most detailed picture yet of this
process in several types of studies
embryos of different stages were
separated into individual cells and the
cells are sequestered away in droplets
of oil what kind of cell am I looking at
here to find out
the researchers sequenced each cell's
messenger RNA which reflects active
genes each cell type has a profile set
of active genes that define its identity
as a muscle cell or a type of brain cell
how do I track a cell through time in
one line of experiments
researchers analyzed some 92,000
zebrafish cells and gathered data from
seven different embryo stages to help
tie the cells to a time point they had a
genetic barcode DNA to the cytoplasm of
some of the single-cell embryos these
are many tiny pieces of unique DNA that
will be incorporated over time into the
genomes of daughter cells by the end of
the experiment
the combinations of barcodes reveal how
the cells are related thus they could
trace each zebrafish cells fate through
time to see how a single cell gave rise
to a variety of specialized cells such
as heart nerves and skin what can this
tell us
this approach is already yielding
results developmental biologists have
thought that once the cell starts down a
path to become say a muscle cell that it
would not stray but researchers observed
some zebrafish cells switch to different
new types as indicated by the change in
what genes were active after they should
have been well committed to a certain
faith in frogs gene activities showed
that even when an embryo looks like an
undifferentiated blob cells are already
starting down the paths to their
eventual identities
but these tools researchers can also see
how development differs from one animal
to the next or even learn our recipe for
coaxing different cell types from stem
cells
[Music]